[Musique]
chez le plateau d'interdît date à dire
je reçois aujourd'hui le journaliste au
wali bordas pour tout ça pour ça un
livre enquête sur les actuels élus de
l'assemblée nationale je reçois
également un habitué n'aurait pour son
septième roman dans l'ombre des hommes
un roman sur le dénigrement mais aussi
sur le fait que les femmes sont presque
toujours considéré à travers les
agissements de leur mari ou compagnon
alors que l'un vers ce n'est pas vrai on
ne reproche pas aux hommes les travers
de leurs compagnes et je reçois
également le pianiste maxime zecchini
pour son anthologie des oeuvres pour la
main gauche le neuvième disque de la
série est consacrée à la musique de film
et on commence tout de suite par ce qui
caractérise notre époque
voici vos réponses en images on commence
par la vôtre maxime bikini alors qui est
ce oui bonjour frais verrait alors
écoutez c'est rémy julienne et voilà en
tant que grand cinéphile
j'étais très heureux de pouvoir lui
rendre hommage car les films auxquels il
a participé on baignait mon enfance et
c'est vrai que je me dis toujours qu'une
cascade et bien c'est fait de plein de
petits ajustements
c'est un vrai casse tête et je me dis qu
en cette semaine où le gouvernement
réfléchit à nour confiné et dans quelles
conditions
eh bien c'était un hommage tout à fait
d'actualité entre voilà la mise en
oeuvre d'une cascade et le prochain
confinement qui malheureusement nous
attend mais en tout cas un hommage à
rémy julienne dont j'admirais le talent
est là il gênait votre image à vous ce
sont les réseaux sociaux oui parce que
les réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui pose la
question de la notion de vérité et du
sens critique qu'il mène à la
polarisation des opinions on le voit
partout
c'est aussi l'espace où peuvent
s'exprimer toutes les manipulations
qu'elle vienne d'un individu lambda ou
des plus puissants comme on a pu le voir
lors des dernières élections américaines
par exemple mais pas uniquement
et je pense que c'est un sujet qui
mérite une réflexion générale sur le sur
le pouvoir qu'ont sur nos sociétés ces
réseaux sociaux on en reparlera tout à
l'heure en parlant de votre roman enfin
wali bordas votre image à vous c'est
babar
pourquoi barça pourrait paraître cocasse
mais en fait j'ai choisi d'abord parce
que en fin de semaine dernière sur sur
france culture il ya eu une émission qui
a parlé du célèbre dessin animé on
connaît tous et que personnellement je
l'adoré quand j'étais enfant et et qui
l'accusé d'incarner l'apologie du
colonialisme
pour une raison qui était que baba après
avoir adopté les écoutions des humains
rentrer dans sa forêt devient le roi et
apprend aux autres les éléphants à se
civiliser
et selon moi ce type d'idéologie est
assez assez révélateur de l'époque dans
laquelle on vit où il ya de nouvelles
idéologies qui apparaissent comme comme
l'indigénisme comme le des colonnades
houleux des colonialismes l'antispécisme
la cancel culture qui ont émergé aux
états unis et qui arrivent petit à petit
en france notamment dans les universités
et je voulais voilà passé un petit clin
d'oeil à babar puisque c'est un
phénomène qui personnellement
l'intérêt c'est une enquête de plus en
plus et bien commençons
[Musique]
wally bordas êtes donc journaliste
journaliste au figaro et vous venez de
co écrire avec nedjma brahim qui elle
est journaliste à médiapart tout ça pour
ça chez plon un livre enquête sur le
renouvellement de l'assemblée nationale
qui s'est opérée en 2017 dans le sillage
de l'élection d' emmanuel macron 404
députés sur 577 n'avait jamais siégé à
l'offre semblait auparavant et 189
n'avait même jamais été élu on n'avait
jamais vu ça
c'est un mouvement un euro un
renouvellement vraiment inédit dans la
vème république
d'autant que parmi ces nouveaux élus il
ya un nombre très très grande de femmes
notamment qui sont près de 40 % à
arriver dans les travées de l'hémicycle
il ya nombre de d'élus qui viennent du
monde de l'entreprise qui avait eu
aucune expérience sélective mais surtout
aucune expérience politique militante
auparavant donc c'est tout nouveau il
arrive à l'assemblée nationale ils
veulent changer les choses ils veulent
renouveler la politique et on a voulu se
plonger dans leur quotidien puisque eux
n'y connaissais rien on voulait voir si
ce pari du renouvellement était réussi
ce pari du changement était réussie et
donc on a mené cette enquête de près
d'un an et demi en les rencontrant en
allant voir les les séances de questions
au gouvernement à l'entraîner dans l'est
dans les couloirs de l'assemblée
nationale
alors ce qu'on reproche à cette
législature c'est celle son aide son
amateurisme ça paraît logique d'abord
puisque comme vous l'avez dit la plupart
d'entre eux n'avaient jamais été députée
une grande partie n'avait jamais été élu
mais en même temps c'est bizarre de
reprocher leur amateurisme à des gens au
moment même où
on lutte contre la professionnalisation
du monde politique
on avait fait des différentes lois
contre le cumul contre le renouvellement
des mandats
justement pour que on est plus affaire à
des professionnels de la politique alors
il faudrait savoir
on veut on veut des professionnels où on
veut des amateurs mais il faut choisir
c'est vrai que c'était un indé paris
d'emmanuel mâcon d'arriver à l'assemblée
nationale et de la renouveler avec des
nouveaux élus qui n'avait jamais eu
d'expérience auparavant et c'était ce
qui était demandé un par une partie de
la population qui aujourd'hui ex-hec
finalement c'est nouveau des élus ce
qu'il faut dire quand même c'est que
constatant cette période qui a une haine
vis-à-vis du politique qui est assez
grande et ces nouveaux élus quand on les
a rencontrés passer de l'amateurisme etc
mais nous ils nous ont ils nous ont
parlé de cet amateurisme en nous disant
qu' il était finalement sain au début
mais ça n'a pas plu à la population qui
leur a reproché le fait de finalement
très vite à la botte du pouvoir de voter
tous les textes du gouvernement les yeux
fermés d'être ce qu'on appelle des
godillots et est finalement aussi
d'avoir fait de nombreuses erreurs à ses
portes
on pense notamment on raconte dans le
livre à ses erreurs celle de majid el
guerrab ce nouvel élu qui arrivent et
qui trois semaines après son élection
mais un coup de casque à son adversaire
politique pour ea sports l'ancien ancien
camarade à lui socialiste et le plonge
dans le coma
finalement ces nouveaux élus qui
arrivait sans expérience ont renouvelé
des erreurs qui avaient déjà été
commises il y en a eu
nombreuses pendant le quinquennat on
peut aussi prendre part les deux de
laëtitia avia qui a été accusé de
harcèlement par le nombre de ses
collaborateurs qui aujourd'hui est sous
le coup d'une enquête et on peut aussi
parler des erreurs collectives qui ont
été
commises par ces députés qui n'ont pas
forcément plaider en leur faveur
quand on leur reproche leur suivisme l'a
aussi fait quand même un petit peu
amusant parce que il faut ne pas
connaître la constitution de la vème
république pour ne pas avoir compris que
depuis le début
donc il ya plus d'un demi siècle
maintenant presque trois quarts de
siècle de vie le début la les députés
n'ayant pas de pouvoir ou quasiment pas
à l'assemblée nationale sont rivés dans
un rôle de godillots comme on les
appelle depuis belle lurette on n'a pas
attendu la les élus la république en
marche pour parler de parti godillot
effectivement et c'est ce qu'on raconte
dans le livre la précédente législature
avait été marquée quand même par
françois hollande et et cette candeur et
justement cette candeur qui a empêché
françois hollande de gouverner
correctement nous ce qu'on voit avec
avec ces nouveaux élus et leur soit
disant suivisme c'est que finalement il
y en a beaucoup qui aurait voulu ne pas
suivre qui aurait voulu ne pas voter
aveuglément les consignes du
gouvernement mais que depuis le début
ils se sont engagés à suivre
une promesse qui était celle d'emmanuel
mâcon ils ont signé pour un programme
donc ils ont voté ce programme est ce
finalement qui ont essayé d'avoir des
avis divergents ce soient eux mêmes ni
côté et on en parlera peut-être après
ont quitté ce parti majoritaire soit ont
été mis ou même en dehors de ce parti en
étant exclus je pense notamment aux
députés
sébastien nadeau qui avaient voté à
l'époque contre le budget on sait que
voter contre le budget c'est toujours
quelque chose qui est irrémédiable et
qui est impardonnable pour pour la
majorité
est-ce qu'on peut pas dire aussi que la
fidélité des élus lrm haut à la
politique du président de la république
est-ce que c'est pas lié aussi au fait
qu'ils ont tous été élus non pas sur
leurs qualités qui leur étaient propres
le
puisque la plupart étaient des inconnus
complet mais uniquement parce qu'il y
avait la photo d'imad yonne macro sur
sur la fiche avec eux certains disaient
que en juin 2017 n'importe quel jeu
c'est pas un homme n'aurait été élu si
c'était revendiquer des maillots le
maquereau donc c'est un peu logique
quand même que qui le lui rendent en
votant pour
pour le porte sur mon gouvernement
d'ailleurs c'est marrant ce que vous
racontez puisque si on se souvient au
départ il ya même certains candidats
la reine qui ont appris qu'ils s'étaient
c'était candidats à la télévision et on
se rappelle notamment de la commission
d'investiture qui sélectionner ses
candidats et qui était c'était du jamais
vu finalement avec dédé des petits
jeunes qui débarquent est qui qui venait
de du mouvement les jeunes avec macron
qui faisait passer des entretiens avec
des centaines des centaines de personnes
qui avaient candidaté en ligne puisque
les candidatures pour la devinière
députés se faisait en ligne ils ont reçu
énormément et ça a donné des scènes
assez cocasses puisque on avait des
jeunes de 19 20 ans encore en école ou
tuent tout juste diplômés de grandes
écoles qui faisait passer des entretiens
à des personnes très qualifiées qui
était dans le monde de l'entreprise
qu'elle est une grande expérience
professionnelle beaucoup plus que ces
jeunes en question et qui leur demander
pourquoi ils voulaient s'engager
pourquoi est ce qu'ils voulaient suivre
le projet d'emmanuel marques ont donc ça
c'était assez amusant mais est ce que ça
ne serait pas ça au fond on a des
fantasmes de démocratie directe est ce
que ce ne serait pas ça une forme de
cesse que ça dépasse qui nous attend si
on allait de plus en plus va la
démocratie directe
ce serait ça il faudrait interviewer les
candidats
pour savoir où ils veulent nous emmener
vu qu'on ne les connaîtraient pas au
fond exactement
et d'ailleurs il y en a beaucoup de ces
nouveaux élus là qui aujourd'hui qui
déjà dès le début l'avez dit vous avez
dit nous on ne présente que pour ces
élections là si on est élu on fera cinq
ans et puis on s'ennuiera et du coup
aujourd'hui c'est intéressant de voir le
contraste avec avec le début où
finalement il y en a énormément qui se
sont habitués à cette à ce nouveau
métier ce nouveau rôle qu'ils ont et qui
souhaite aujourd'hui se représenter et
et continuer à travailler avec cette
majorité
mais il y en a pas tant que ça qu'ils
veulent sur présenter quand on lit votre
livre on a l'impression que beaucoup
ceux qui veulent rester dans la
politique veulent voudrait devenir mère
parce qu'ils se rendent compte qu'ils
auraient bien plus de pouvoir en tant
que maire on peut cheveux davantage
changer les choses en tant que maire et
puis là aussi c'est la première
assemblée non cumularde puisque la loi
était passé sous françois hollande on
peut plus cumuler le mandat de maire
avec celui de député et beaucoup se
rendent compte que au fond ils n'ont
aucune en n'ayant aucune aucun ancrage
local
ben non seulement ils n'ont pas de
pouvoir mais en fait ils savent pas ce
qui se passe non plus c'est vrai qu'il y
en a beaucoup qui ont des désillusions
qui on est et désenchanté sens on est
rendu compte au fil de notre enquête
ils sont arrivés à l'assemblée nationale
ils savaient pas en fait ce qui était
que ce rôle d'élu ce rôle de député qui
en plus où la vue est dit il était à
redéfinir puisque avant les députés
pouvaient avoir le cumul des deux
mandats du coup que vous pouvez être
mère en même temps que m conseiller
régional et c'est là ils sont arrivés à
l'assemblée nationale
ils ont su réinventer en quelque sorte
le rôle du député et on était déçu
pourquoi parce que ils sont rendus
compte qu'en fait il n'avait que très
peu de pouvoir que ce soit localement
dans la circonscription ou à l'assemblée
nationale pour poser des abonnements les
faire valider pour
voter les lois ils sont rendus compte
que en fait ce dont on parlait tout à
l'heure ils étaient finalement
totalement tributaire et devait voter
toutes les lois tous les textes qui
était proposée par le gouvernement et en
plus ils se sont rendus compte que comme
ils étaient très nombreux
c'est une pause et le six nouveaux élus
pardon où nombre d'entre eux n'ont pas
eu les responsabilités qu'ils auraient
aimé avoir à être responsables d'un
texte pouvoir avoir des responsabilités
être whip beaucoup d'entre eux ne l'ont
pas été ont été énormément déçu je me
souviens de beaucoup de députés
quand on est rencontrée au début on a
commencé notre enquête un an après leur
élection il était encore dans le parti
présidentiel
et il disait je me sent coincée je me
sens en difficulté dans cette majorité
j'ai l'impression que que je suis un
playmobil que je suis là uniquement pour
voter les lois en séance de nuit
qu'on ne me donne pas de responsabilité
on a ils ont été élus eux en se disant
qu'il venait du monde de l'entreprise
qu'ils avaient une spécialité
il y en a qui était un infirmier il y en
a qui étaient dans les ressources
humaines etc
ils pensaient qu'ils allaient être
utilisés pour ses spécialités à
l'assemblée nationale qu'ils allaient
pouvoir apporter quelque chose de plus
et que finalement cette société civile
elle allait pouvoir permettre à
l'assemblée nationale d'apporter de la
technique et e sont rendus compte qu'en
fait il n'était pas du tout utilisé sur
ces sujets-là 12,7 d'élise illusion qui
a eu lieu
petit à petit au fil de la législature
est en effet pour revenir au rôle de
mère beaucoup finalement se sont
réorientés on essayait de se présenter
aux élections municipales avec la
réussite qu'on leur connaît puisque ça a
été une véritable hécatombe pour le
parti présidentiel et une grande partie
d'entre eux sont retournés depuis à
l'assemblée nationale est ce que au fond
le procès qu'on fait a assez cette
majorité parce que c'est surtout la
majorité la république en marche qui est
mise en accusation pour un acte horrible
poursuivre
pour tout ce que vous avez dit est ce
que font le procès n'ait pas plutôt
celui de notre régime politique actuel
c'est à dire au fond des députés dont le
mandat est le même que celui du
président de la république
donc c'est le mandat 50 qui est du
président de la république qui est mis
en accusation
c'est le toutes les lois sur le non
cumul et le non renouvellement des
mandats qui crée au fond un personnel
politique totalement amateur c'est vrai
mais c'est comme ça qu'on l'a voulu et
et qui est une totalement dans la roue
du président de la république qui se
fait élire dans la foulée de son
élection à lui et qui lui sert
uniquement à voter les lois qu'il a
l'intention de faire passer au fond
c'est ça le régime politique français
aujourd'hui il est assez loin celui de
la vème république voulu par le général
de gaulle en 58 et et on en fait le
procès en faisant le procès de la
majorité actuelle
en effet c'est ce pont c'est ce qu'on
essaye de questionner dans notre enquête
effectivement les élections légistatives
suivent la présidentielle de de quelques
jours donc forcément les élus
actuellement sont élus dans le sillage
du nouveau président de la république
est effectivement la majorité ll est
souvent pour le président de la
république puisque les citoyens souhaite
lui donner quand même le pouvoir
d'appliquer le programme pour lequel il
a été élu
ça n'a pas toujours été le cas il faut
s'en rappeler quand même et à l'époque
où ce n'était pas le cas on assistait
souvent à des cohabitations on se
souvient notamment avec mitterrand qui
avait vu comme un ministre jacques
chirac et mitterrand qui avait comme
premier ministre edouard balladur et
finalement c'était des cohabitations qui
finalement pouvait bloquer en quelque
sorte le président de la république dans
la mise en place de son programme
depuis ça a été réformé effectivement
les législatives suivent la
présidentielle et de fait le parlement
est totalement inféodée
à l'exécutif alors ce qu'il ya de
nouveau dans cette dans cette
législature c'est c'est que au fond vous
remarqué qu'il ya beaucoup de couples
qui ont volé en éclats il ya un taux de
divorces chez ces nouveaux élus qui
semble d'après ce que vous dites bien
supérieur avec ce qu'on n'avait connu et
essai dans tous les sens un adore ça
comment explique-t-on pourquoi est-ce
qu'on divorce tombeau se séparent ton à
ce point de sa compagne ou son compagnon
quand on est un prime aux députés depuis
de 2017
ça c'est vrai que c'est quelque chose
qui nous a énormément surpris
au fil de nos rencontres avec ses élus
et vraiment je je je ne vais pas en
rajouter à chaque fois qu'on rencontrait
en élus qu'ils soient de la république
en marche ou ou de l'opposition
il nous parlait de ce taux de divorce ou
de séparation très élevé lors de cette
législature et on en a même rencontré
qui avait peint subi justement des
séparations ou des divorces
ça s'explique de plusieurs manières la
première c'est qu'en fait il ya eu un
nombre d'élus très très jeune et en tout
cas beaucoup plus jeune que ce n'était
le cas auparavant qui a été qui a été
élu dans la foulée de l'élection d'
emmanuel macron des jeunes députés qui
n'avaient pas l'habitude d'avoir une vie
politique qui était auparavant
tranquillement dans leur vie en
entreprise qu'ils pouvaient rentrer le
soir voire leur leur femme ou leur mari
et leurs enfants et qui du jour au
lendemain se retrouve à l'assemblée
nationale une grande partie du temps le
reste du temps en circonscription avec
un emploi du temps très chargé à devoir
aller à des inaugurations
à des brocantes serrer des mains et c
est finalement ne plus avoir beaucoup de
temps pour sa famille en plus de ça au
début de cette législature il ya eu dans
la majorité
un nombre d'élus important qui a plaidé
pour le fait de bosser toujours plus de
travailler énormément ce qui a poussé
nombre d'entre eux a vraiment s'investir
énormément que ce soit en commission que
ce soit l'assemblée nationale dans dans
le travail que ce soit pour aller dans
les ministères essayé de faire passer
leurs idées et que ce soit aussi en
circonscription pour rencontrer leurs
leurs concitoyens ce qui fait que
finalement ils ont énormément oublier
leur vie de famille et ça a créé des
tensions et puis finalement des
séparations
on rencontrait aussi par exemple une une
députée qui nous racontait pourquoi elle
avait fini par se séparer de son mari
parce qu en fait celui ci avait
finalement est en quelque sorte jaloux
de sa réussite sociale et de son
ascension et elle nous disait que par
exemple aux repas repas avec des amis
c'était c'est elle qui était devenu un
peu plus intéressante à qui ont posé des
questions et qu'il avait eu énormément
de mal à le supporter de malal vivre et
finalement ça a créé des tensions dans
le couple et que vous savez a fini par
se terminer
et puis il ya aussi un autre acteur
c'est que l'assemblée nationale il ya eu
des rencontres forcément des jeunes gens
qui débarquent dans un nouvel
environnement qui sont ensemble tout le
temps qu'ils votent des lois ensemble
qui après quand ils sortent de
l'hémicycle on compare à un verre
ensemble mais finalement ça crée des
affinités et ça crée une nouvelle
amourette qui peuvent faire exploser un
coup en fait vous nous raconter une
émission de télé réalité là au fait
comme s'ils étaient enfermés dans une
bulle et condamné en fait à avoir des
histoires d'amour pour finir ce qui
caractérise cette cette majorité
également c'est que mais qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens enfin beaucoup d'élus
qui louent quitter le palais
la république en marche a perdu
quasiment un élu par mois depuis depuis
juin 2017 c'est énorme c'est beaucoup
c'est qu'il en soit 45 ou 46 maintenant
et ça aussi c'est assez nouveau en fait
ils sont allés créer des d'autres
groupes parlementaires qui souvent
d'ailleurs continuent de voter en faveur
du gouvernement mais enfin ils sont plus
la république en marche
oui on a beaucoup qui ont quitté le
parti le parti majoritaire en est une
vous avez le bon chiffre
ces 44 45 je crois et ça s'est fait
petit à petit finalement il ya eu des
périodes où il en est lui un peu plus et
d'autre qu'un ami un peu moins et on a
eu au début on a parlé de mes chutes
admirable forcément c'était un peu
retentissant c'était un cas de violence
donc là ça a été direct et rapide
et puis après au fur et à mesure il y en
a eu qui sont partis pour des
divergences d'opinion avec avec
finalement l'exécutif certains qui
avaient plutôt une fibre très
environnementale qui espié et qui
estimait que le gouvernement ne prenez
pas assez en compte les problématiques
écologiques d'autres qui pendant le vote
de la réforme des retraites n'ont pas
apprécié que le gouvernement ait recours
ou 49,3 parce qu'il avait passé des
heures et des heures dans l'hémicycle a
essayé de faire voter tous les articles
qui ont été très déçu de ça d'autre part
ce que c'était il était de l'ailé gauche
on a énormément parlé pendant cette
législature les poches de la majorité
avec des poids lourds comme aurélien
taché ou matthieu orphelin qui ont
décidé de finalement quitter le
mouvement parce que j'estimais que la
politique du gouvernement pencher un peu
trop à droite
et puis d'autres juste parce que ils ont
été effectivement déçu de ne pas être
considérés à leur juste valeur de ne pas
être pris en compte et de ne pas être
appelé sur certains textes qu'ils
estimaient qu'il aurait été légitime
donc finalement en effet vous en avait
parlé il ya eu des groupes qui ont été
créés
a été créée à la gauche finalement de la
république en marche par aurélien tâche
et matthieu orphelin peuvent l'apporter
à qui finalement n'a pas tenu puisqu'il
n'avait plus le nombre d'élus
nécessaires pour faire un groupe
parlementaire
lille moulins debout un autre beau un
petit peu à droite de la république en
marche avec des d'anciens élus du groupe
udi agir donc plutôt du côté de agir
contre et un groupe qui existe
aujourd'hui encore mais qui finalement
lui renforce un petit peu la majorité
puisque il vient apporter des élus qui
était chez lui des i et qui finalement
le vote aujourd'hui les et les lois
proposées par le gouvernement
et puis deux puis petit à petit c'est ça
c'est un petit peu ralenti la depuis
depuis la sortie un retentissant tu de
certains d'entre eux après la première
vague du coc vide et là il y en a deux
trois qui sont partis la dernière en
date étant optionnel hazard qui disait
estimé ne plus vouloir être la caution
de gauche de cette majorité
je vous remercie wally bordas tout ça
pour ça ça vient de paraître chez plon
ont fait une pause on se retrouve juste
après avec anaïs jeanneret
[Musique]
dans l'ombre des hommes à nice jeanneret
qui vient de paraître chez albin michel
et votre septième roman c'est l'histoire
d'une femme qui quitte son mari qui est
secrétaire d'état elle le quitte en
plein mouvement des filets jaunes parce
qu'elle découvre qu'il est corrompu et
infidèle et qu'elle réalise qu'elle ne
l'est plus depuis longtemps mais très
vite sur les réseaux sociaux dans les
articles de presse elle se retrouve
impliqué dans ces malversations on lui
prête une influence qu'elle n'a jamais
eu des intentions qui ne sont pas les
siennes
c'est ça pour vous être dans l'ombre des
hommes être dans l'un des 1 dans l'ombre
des hommes c'est en fait se retrouver
étiqueté comme la compagne de la
personne avec qui on est et où on a été
en mettant complètement de côté
l'identité propre de cette personne en
l'occurrence de cette femme et
et en fait en voulant raconter cette
histoire là ce qui m'intéressait c'était
de montrer finalement la collision entre
l'archaïsme de notre société qui
effectivement continue de devoir les
femmes à travers ce prisme là et en même
temps
cette forme de communication ultra
moderne qui passe par les réseaux
sociaux et cette collision
finalement
traduit je trouve assez bien notre
époque et il m'a paru intéressante dans
le cas de votre votre héroïne
il se trouve qu'elle est romancière mais
à un moment il révise qu'elle ne fait
pas assez parler d'elle au fond ça
laisse toute la place aux élucubrations
et et qui a laissé finalement un vide
dans son elle n'a pas créé disons
d'identité numérique et quand ce torrent
on va lui tomber dessus
elle va s'apercevoir en fait presque de
sa responsabilité
c'est à dire que cet espace vide est une
possibilité
effectivement à toutes les élucubrations
toutes les fausses vérités les calomnies
éventuellement
et elle prend conscience à ce moment là
qu'il faut s'exprimer alors que jusque
là il lui semblait que cette femme est
romancière et que son travail suffisait
mais elle réalise que à cette époque
sans doute ce n'est pas tout à fait
suffisant
il ya un mot que vous employez plusieurs
fois c'est le mot dénigrement et c'est
vraiment un roman sur le dénigrement
or le dénigrement c'est aussi la rançon
de notre époque
plus on est connu en france aujourd'hui
mais je pense que c'est pareil dans les
autres pays
plus on est dénigré je crois que c'est
emmanuel macron récemment qui a dit la
française et ils 66 millions de
procureur il ya 66 millions de
procureurs près vous dénigrez alors
selon votre célébrité vous allez dénigré
par plus ou moins un but ou moins grand
nombre d'entre eux oui parce que
aujourd'hui on est dans un monde qui est
gouverné beaucoup par l'émotion et aussi
par l'immédiateté et face à celui qui
s'exprime le plus fort finalement
gagne le terrain et c'est ce qui se
passe c'est à dire que peut un individu
seul quand quand un ensemble un groupe
déverse sa réalise sa vérité qui n'est
pas une réalité mais seul contre ça
c'est extrêmement compliqué c'est le
rapport d'un individu contre la vox
populi en fait
mais justement c'est aussi ce qui est
intéressant c'est que c'est un drôle de
combat qu'elle mène tout à coup
puisqu'en face d'elle elle n'a elle à
tout le monde elle n'a personne au fond
personne n'a d'intérêt particulier à
l'aide dénigrer on la dénigre pour les
dénigrer
on lui prête je le répète des intentions
qu'elle n'a jamais eu des collusions
qu'elle n'a pas uniquement parce qu'elle
est la femme de ce secrétaire d'état et
et mais au fond de nos fauves en face
d'elle il ya personne n'y a personne de
précis
oui c'est tout c'est la nature même des
réseaux sociaux
vous ne savez pas qui vous avez en face
de vous et ça rend extrêmement démunies
que ça soit le collégien ou ou des gens
qui ont des responsabilités le problème
reste à peu près le même en définitif
l'anonymat qui est un semis et une fin
qui relatif puisque en réalité les
hébergeurs aurez accès mais finalement
ne font pas toujours le
n'exerce pas toujours le contrôle sur ce
qui peut être dit et c'est c'est très
complexe
c'est pour ça que le ce livre j'ai ça
m'intéressait d'écrire ce livre parce
que je pense que c'est vraiment un sujet
qui qui qui peut toucher potentiellement
tout le monde
enfin ça dépend avec qui on est mariés
ou avec qui on vit quand même mais vous
dites justement dans ce livre naïve
j'aimerais qu'on ne comptait ni aux
femmes une identité à part entière elles
sont d'abord considéré à travers les
agissements de leur mari comme une
extension de leur mari au fond et que ce
n'est pas le cas pour les hommes
les hommes ne sont pas redevables des
des actes même délictueux de leur
famille ou de leur compagne il y aurait
une mieux mais symétrie là oui ça m'a
fait réfléchir effectivement alors je
pense que c'est un mélange de choses
d'abord je pense que votre invité
précédent parlait de deux de couple qui
s'était séparé parce que la femme avait
des fonctions qui faisait que l'on
parlait plus volontiers de ce qu'elles
faisaient que son compagnon mais disons
que pour l'instant c'est sans doute
encore moins fréquents que l' inverse
mais finalement ça se reproduit ce
schéma se reproduit à tous les niveaux
de la société c'est à dire que je pense
que dans une petite ville de province
la femme du pharmacien va être confronté
assez facilement à à ce même problème
donc c'est un mélange de fer voilà on
assez les vestiges d'une société encore
patriarcale et qui fait que les femmes
souvent au moins de pouvoirs que leur
homme
et même quand elles en ont elles ont
sans doute peut-être une forme de
discrétion ou en tout cas on leur prête
moins de pouvoir
qu'elles ne peuvent en avoir mais je
suis sûr que j'imagine que vous pouvez
vous tromper si demain une femme
ministre était accusé comme l'est le
personnage de votre rendement de
malversations ou de corruption
je suis sûr va j'espère penser que non
j'ai trait sur son mari ou son compagnon
le même regard suspicieux qu'on jette
sur votre héroïne
je pense que vous avez raison c'est une
question de pouvoir si les femmes sont
en situation de pouvoir ça retombera sur
leur compagnon ou sur la marie de la
même manière oui sûrement mais on est
encore dans ce monde patriarcal qui fait
qu'il ya encore beaucoup plus d'hommes
qui ont des postes de pouvoir que les
femmes mais effectivement sans doute que
à terme les choses vont bouger les
choses bougent d'ailleurs les choses les
choses bougent déjà mais à l'instant où
nous sommes aujourd'hui on est encore on
est encore beaucoup plus là dedans et et
j'apporterai peut-être une nuance c'est
à dire que même votre femme ministre
je ne suis pas sûr qu'on porterait
finalement un regard
nécessairement aussi biaisé sur son
compagnon que sur la compagne d'un
ministre homme
on verra on verra quand ça va arriver là
votre roman est intéressant aussi c'est
que vous montrez bien à quel point on
peut se défendre face à la justice
et on ne peut rien contre la vox populi
ah oui oui oui c est la justice par
rapport par rapport aux réseaux sociaux
et des relativement impuissante aussi
donc voilà pour autant cette forme le
mon héroïne elle agit quand même serre
que elle n'est pas complètement
elles ne restent pas sans rien faire
d'abord dès le départ elle s'en va ce
qui est quand même un acte fort parce
que parce qu'elle se retrouve dans une
situation de notre immense solitude
effectivement et petit à petit elle va
donc mesurer sa situation et décidé de
prendre la parole et de reprendre sa vie
en main et de retrouver son identité
pleine et entière mais effectivement ça
demande sa demande du courage et puis
sans doute une forme de d'inventivité
là il est plus difficile de se défendre
contre les bucks public devant la
justice mais il est aussi plus difficile
en général de se défendre contre une
injustice au fond et il est plus facile
de se défendre quand on est coupable le
passeport s'est préparé à se défendre
que quand on est innocent parce qu'on
n'avait pas on n'avait rien prévu
on ne savait pas qu'on aurait à se
défendre et c'est donc forcément plus
difficile et puis c'est une plus
difficile en général de prouver qu'on
n'a pas fait quelque chose
ce qui est plus difficile prouver qu'on
c'est presque insurmontable au fond
c'est très difficile d'être innocent oui
oui et c'est d'autant plus que c'est une
c'est une violence
très forte c'est à dire d'être accusé de
quelque chose qu'on a fait ben voilà
c'est le jeu d'une certaine façon quand
vous êtes accusé de quelque chose que
vous n'avez pas fait c'est vraiment le
comble de l'injustice
c'est la double peine d'une certaine
façon en tout cas c'est ce qui se passe
pour mon héroïne lll part parce qu'elle
désapprouve les les agissements de son
mari et elle est punie pour les
agissements pour gt elle s'en va donc
donc oui c'est effectivement difficile
c'est une c'est une vraie violence
psychique je prends soin
c'est dans l'ombre des hommes le titre
de votre septième roman anaïs général ça
vienne paraître chez albin michel
[Musique]
maxime bucchini vous vous êtes pianiste
et vous continuez votre anthologie des
oeuvres pour la main gauche
le neuvième album est consacrée à la
musique de film vous n'êtes pas le seul
musicien classique a cédé aux sirènes
des bandes originales un renaud capuçon
l'a fait il ya peu tout un album
consacré aux musiques de films même
khatia buniatishvili a fini par
enregistrer un morceau d'ennio morricone
sur son dernier album vous trouvez pas
c'est un peu triste que là la grande
majorité des gens aujourd'hui ne
connaissent plus la musique orchestrale
qu'à travers les musiques de films alors
en fait ma démarche a été très
différente des artistes que vous avez
cités parce que donc moi je fais une
anthologie en dix disques qui montre
tout ce qu'on peut faire avec la main
gauche et il se trouve que on peut aussi
faire des transcriptions musique de film
à la main gauche c'est la raison pour
laquelle ce disque existe mais voilà il
aurait pu arriver il y a déjà quelques
années
venir dans encore plusieurs années voilà
c'est vraiment le hasard du calendrier
qui fait qu il sort aujourd'hui
mais c'est un cette année ce qu'on fait
partie d'un tout j'ai bien compris
maxime lui qui ne s'est pas par
opportunisme que vous l'avez fait mais
c'est dans un souci d'anthologie on
valoir
néanmoins vous ne trouvez pas triste
qu'aujourd'hui la musique orchestrale
bas à part les bandes originales des
musiques de films
les gens ne la connaissent plus est au
fond il trouve ça super beau john
williams parce qu'ils n'ont pas entendu
méthodes et des tops et rachmaninoff
alors c'est sûr ce qui est intéressant
c'est que les personnes qui ne
connaissent pas les taux avec mind of
vont écouter du jazz louis gates
et si ça les intéresse ils vont
découvrir que john williams puise son
inspiration dans tchaïkovski d'encore
gold dans strauss est peut-être en
espère ça puisque cela puisse les amener
à découvrir les disques de ses
prédécesseurs voilà ce serait ce serait
comme un passeur voilà de savoir mais
vous écoutez tout de suite
interprétant un extrait de out of africa
qui n'est pas de john williams mais de
john barry
le compositeur également de nombreuses
musiques de films dont les musiques de
films de james bond on écoute out of
africa qui figurent sur cet album
[Musique]
m
oh
à
e
[Musique]
en
alors ce on l'a vu sur cette petite
vidéo vous d'interpréter ce morceau que
de la main gauche une transcription qui
a été fait de la musique de john barry
musique orchestrale
au fond vous infliger une double peine
déjà il faut la transcrire pour le piano
uniquement on enlèverait violon dans les
blés cuivre on enlève tour mais plus que
du piano mais en plus vous vous voulez
que tout ça tienne avec une seule main à
main gauche française par double double
défi voilà c c'est le but de ces disques
c'est de montrer que l'on peut tout
faire avec la main gauche qu'il n'y a
absolument aucune restriction aucune
limite et que même les plus grandes
oeuvres orchestrales avec la nombre de
musiciens
très important eh bien peut être
remplacée par seulement cinq doigts
voilà c'est un travail absolument
passionnant très créatif qui demande
beaucoup d'astuces beaucoup de devoirs
là de petites petites créativité voilà
pour faire sonner le piano comme un
orchestre mais au départ vous êtes
gaucher c'est pour ça c'est ça qui vous
a donné envie de cette de cette
anthologie de parce que on va les voir
il ya huit albums qui sont sortis avant
celui-ci vous c'est le premier sur le
cinéma tous les autres c'était de la
musique classique c'est quoi le point de
départ c'est ce que vous êtes gaucher ou
pas alors je suis pas du tout gauche et
je suis droitier est le point de départ
c'est en fait j'ai comme beaucoup de
pjanic et travailler le très célèbre en
tout cas pour les musiciens classiques
le concerto de ravel pour la main gauche
et j'ai trouvé ça absolument passionnant
que parce que si on ferme les yeux on a
vraiment l'impression que les deux mains
joue et du coup j'ai fait des recherches
sur internet et je me suis aperçu qu'il
y avait plus de 600 oeuvres qui avait
été écrite pour la main gauche et que
très peu avait enregistré ces pièces
vraiment un deux trois pianistes dans
toute l'histoire du piano et j'ai
proposé donc ce projet à mon label de
disques advitam record ce qui m'a
encouragé souvent que c'était une très
bonne idée de faire découvrir ses pièces
au plus grand nombre parce que elles ont
été écrites par les plus grands
compositeurs et c'est une nouvelle
manière d'aborder le piano une nouvelle
manière de jouer
une manière de découvrir le piano
différentes et que je trouve ça
passionnant ce côté original et unique
et alors c'est vrai que ça vous a valu
d'ailleurs des loges considérable dans
la presse ses huit albums précédents
on va écouter tout de suite justement
une composition de john williams
jurassic park tout le monde la connaît
mais jouer au piano uniquement de la
main gauche
voilà ce que ça donne
[Musique]
e
oh
mais
n
[Musique]
mais si vous avez choisi la main gauche
auriez pu choisir la main droite alors
pas du tout parce que d'ailleurs il ya
600 heures à peu près même encore plus
écrite pour la main gauche et seulement
10 pour la main droite et ça c'est à
cause de la disposition des doigts c'est
à dire qu'en fait je joue la mélodie
avec le pouce et le deuxième doit qui
sont les doigts fort de la main et je
joue l'accompagnement avec les autres
doigts 3 4 5 qui sont les doigts plus
faible de la main en fait ma main droite
est remplacé par m'ont poussé mon
deuxième doit et ma main gauche par les
autres doigts et al'inverse si vous
prenez la main droite
ça voudrait dire qu'il faut jouer fort
la mélodie avec le quatrième ou le
cinquième doigt ce serait très
inconfortable ce serait très fatigant et
je pense qu'on se ferait mal très vite
c'est la raison pour laquelle il existe
si peu d'heures pour la main droite est
temps pour la main gauche
vous vous remettez de temps en temps à
faire jouer votre main droite
est ce que ça vous paraît tout à coup
bizarre ou au contraire le naturel
revient au galop
ben alors le naturel revient au galop
vous savez ya tellement d'années
d'études tellement de travail que voilà
c'est comme le vélo ça ne s'oublie
jamais et moi je maintenant ça fait
tellement d'années que je joue désert
pour la main gauche que je vois
absolument plus la différence quand je
joue d'une main ou de demain je joue du
piano tout simplement des heures
différentes mais c'est toujours un
bonheur égal pour les deux répertoires
et mon cerveau ne fait même plus la
différence entre le jeu à une ou deux
mains vous écoute jouer la la land
alors là c'est de justin hurwitz la la
land de la main gauche
non
et
est ce que est ce que n'importe quelle
oeuvre pourrait convenir
est ce que vous auriez pu mettre
n'importe quelle mélodie et
n'importe quelle musique de film aurait
pu être transcrit pour à la main gauche
et aurait fonctionné alors je ne pense
pas tout ça dépend du facture de
l'écriture de la musique de film je
pense par exemple à ennio morricone si
vous prenez ces musique de western qui
sont plus basés sur des motifs
répétitifs ou l'utilisation
d'instruments particulier comme
l'harmonica ou une cithare voilà des ce
sont plus les couleurs des sons qui vont
apporter tout l'intérêt de la musique et
ça je ne pourrai pas de retranscrire au
piano donc par exemple ennio morricone
et pas un très bon compositeur pour des
transcriptions pour la main gauche au
contraire de john williams qui écrit de
manière très classique très traditionnel
très fourni avec beaucoup d'harmonies
comme un grand compositeur classique et
ça c'est beaucoup plus facile et bien
écoutons un autre extrait de john
williams se composait plus exactement
par john williams c'est la bande
originale dite ea qui figure elle aussi
dans cet album on vous écoute
[Musique]
et
oh
qu'est ce que vous répondez à ceux qui
qui pense que tout ça c'est après tout
c'est juste une attraction c'est c'est
un gadget c1 et en quoi ça vous semble
vous fondamental d'avoir enregistré
toute cette anthologie
alors d'abord ce qui est formidable
c'est qu'on est que trois pianistes dans
le monde à le faire et ça c'est très
agréable pour moi de pouvoir faire
découvrir des choses nouvelles de
répertoire classique voilà parce qu'on
joue toujours les oeuvres de chopin dub
et offre un petit peu le même répertoire
donc déjà l'impression d'apporter
quelque chose de nouveau et très
agréable et après à ces personnes je
leur répondrai que brahms a écrit pour
la main gauche je leur répondrai que
franz liszt a écrit pour la main gauche
que camille saint saëns a écrit pour la
main gauche que bartok
donc je me dis que si tout s'est très
très grand compositeur qui sont là pour
l'éternité on écrit pour la main gauche
c'est qu'ils y ont trouvé un intérêt
et voilà je trouve que c'est un
répertoire qui est aussi délivre un
message humain très fort parce que dans
l'histoire de la musique plusieurs
pianistes qui ont été blessés par
exemple à la guerre ont pu continuer
leur carrière de pianiste grâce à ce
répertoire pour la main gauche 7 délivre
le message que face à l'adversité
et bien alors trouve toujours une
solution voilà parce que jouer du piano
d'une massa peut paraître fou et bien
portants c'est possible voilà il ya
toujours une solution grâce au courage
et à la détermination je trouve c'est un
répertoire qui mélangent et un message
humain fort est en même temps beaucoup
de kravis de créativité d'inventivité et
c'est ça qui est formidable dans ce
répertoire qui est très beau et voilà
écrit par les plus grands compositeurs
les divas déjà enregistré neuf albums
cette anthologie contient déjà neuf
albums
est ce qu'il reste encore des oeuvres
enregistrées il ya un dixième album qui
est prévu
et que conviendra-t-il alors on va faire
un 10ème album avec le label c'est
encore une surprise voilà son contenu on
en mettra aussi un dvd qui sera volume
11 à peu près où un volume 10 bis voilà
qui montrera que c'est un répertoire
aussi qui se regarde voilà c'est pas
seulement un répertoire auditifs
mais c'est aussi un répertoire visuels
pour que les personnes voit l'énergie
différentes qu'ont mais lorsqu'on joue
de la main gauche
la gestion du corps voilà la gestion de
l'énergie électrique
quand on joue donc on a trouvé que
c'était intéressant de mettre un dvd
pour montrer aussi le côté visuel est
donc ce sera un coffret 10 ou 11 donc
volume qui sortira qui sera on va dire
le meilleur de la main gauche parce
qu'on aurait pu faire 20 ou 30 cd mais
bon je veux me concentrer justement sur
le meilleur répertoire ou où on ne peut
pas critiquer la qualité musicale
voilà je veux vraiment le meilleur le
plus si ce n'est le plus le plus réussi
de ces pièces merci maxime et bien
j'espère aussi vous entendre bientôt en
concert oeuvre pour la main gauche le
nouvel album consacré aux musiques de
films je vous remercie tous les trois
d'avoir participé à cette émission
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]